so how do you know you're good at it
they'll tell you
i don't have to say much oh really yeah
they'll tell you i could just show you
hi i'm shine reynolds and i'm still on
the lookout i've had some good dates i'm
liking my views that you know i'm saying
it's all good right now charm aren't ya
and i've had some bad dates how do you
think you've done on the date i don't
really give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna lie
about it where are all the decent men
not in my dms that's for sure you get me
i feel like i'm rolling with the man
then what's going on about your fives it
seems like a lot of men don't know how
to treat a lady i'll just manhandle
everything and this girl's putting a
chest and chest in the nuts
will i have better luck this season what
would you do if my ex was after you he
can have you let's find out this
is grilling
my name is tizzy and i'm here to find
some love
i can handle the grid it's definitely
like
i'm an honest person i'm an open book so
there's nothing she's going to ask me
that's going to throw me off behind
every strong man there's a strong woman
you feel me so
i'm just trying to replicate that
hello hello hello hello you're looking
beautiful
nice to meet you ah gentlemen what's
your name tizzy nice to meet you
cheyenne
no that's russian she's sexy he looks
nice clean no tracksuit
so tizzy what do you do i'm a musician
and what do you do i host i run a
project called pure love projects where
we go feed the homeless and stuff so
yeah check it out sometime all right so
you're like a philanthropist i like that
try it i like that i like that i like
that yeah so
oh are you coming with this song oh i
can come with a sophie one look so like
what are you looking for at this date
here i would like you to
surprise me i don't want you to i hope
you don't come like all the other dates
have been so i hope that you could show
me something new something real i'm i
just be myself all the time so that's
all i can do you know i mean so what's
your type on paper i don't really have a
type like
complexion or anything like that i'm
more looking at the mind like if you can
keep up with my mind if you can keep me
interested i like a girl that's
intellectual and has goals you know i'm
saying what's your goals like would you
want to be
five years from now would you see
yourself successful
in a home a few businesses
any kids yeah absolutely how many kids
you wanna have wait hold on i'm supposed
to be asking you the question
so tell me about you what's your goal my
goals
my goal is to impress you baby no lie
my goal is just to keep going the way
i'm going and just literally
be times 10 multiple i want to just keep
creating different streams of income
and just be successful and health for
all my family that's the most important
so what kind of music is it you do i do
a mixture i would say i'm a music artist
i won't call myself a rapper because i
sing i rap i do a mixture of everything
okay i'm like i play instruments as well
so i'm just a musical love dragon 19 out
now baby i think you should listen so
would you say you're a good guy yeah
where i need to be have you ever cheated
yeah i have still yeah i have you know
and i would say no but i admitted it on
tv already that i did so you know i
can't really
yeah
she knows i cheated we keep it roll
around here but they know the truth then
you know hide it find out later
oh i was really liking him but now he's
gone out the window
why are you saying it's so casual i'm
saying it casually because it was a long
time ago i was young
and it was
more like
not physical cheating like more like
emotional cheating like texan no there's
cheating it's obviously still cheating
by definition i do admit i was sorry
said sorry we moved on from it but yeah
i did do that when i was younger like 18
so oh he was 18. yeah like i was i was a
little man you know i mean no but that
still doesn't justify actually it
doesn't justify it but people change so
what we've done to change that what have
i done to change
to being a cheater not do it again
that's a start no i haven't cheated
again so after that relationship i've
already had one relationship after that
and i didn't cheat in that relationship
it came to an end but i didn't cheat
you're looking at me like you don't
really yeah yeah i trust that one i'm
i'm quite easy and understand with many
things but cheating's like
yeah just bottom barrel behavior nah i
can't lie cheating i'm not proud of it
it was one of the ones where i feel like
i was just young and getting a lot of
attention and wasn't really learning how
to deal with it yeah how to navigate
through very softly yeah it's selfish
because you don't think about the other
person like how did she feel and how did
she find out how did she find out well
funny story she went through my phone
while i was sleeping but you know back
in the day it wasn't face id it was the
fun so she like warmed up my thumb by
massaging it
what she just just like i don't just
randomly wake up so she she made it feel
normal in my feet when i say out loud
that's just a bit crazy but you know i
still got love for her we're cool now we
cool i woken up to a bang in the face oh
my god yeah true stories but you know
we're cool we're actually good friends
now how many women do you entertain
though i don't know what's entertaining
what's your definition of entertaining
sleeping with
dating i only sleep for one person at a
time i don't sleep with multiple people
but dating i can be dating multiple
people but i can't sleep with multiple
people how does that work then like so
are you like an open relationship person
cause i'm sure if you're like okay i
don't know no no we're not open close
but then you'll take those people dating
how do you get to know someone you meet
them
maybe on social media or maybe i meet
you at a party or something and then we
go to a date at that point there are you
the only person i meant to be dating i
don't even know who you are how many
women have you slept with she's asking
bear questions damn
so by slept with what do you mean by
slept sex have sex how many women have i
had sex with yes
i actually don't know give me an average
i don't know which means you don't know
it as in it's that many people there's
no not like it's that many here but it's
just like i don't sleep with a girl and
think
one then i don't see people another guy
i think two like i lost my virginity at
a young age how am i going to keep track
for all those years i mean i don't
remember what i did like three days ago
so so is your life like an artist's life
like the party lifestyle and tell the
truth i can't lie my life is really like
two mad opposites like i could be like
driving g-wagons in dubai and i could be
like on the train on the way to flipping
in central london to go do some
groceries yeah i mean like i've got two
mad opposites like sometimes i'm mad lit
and i'm enjoying life and other times
i'm just more just doing normal stuff
like what everyone else does i mean so
how do you find it hard to meet people
that can get past the cheating thing
because for me
i like it's nice that you said homebody
and i don't i'm i i try not to be that
woman that throws your past back in your
face because i like to get through
something
but then if you're like i'm homebody and
it's like yeah just because you're
saying you're home and you're behaving
doesn't mean that you're not misbehaving
because you could be dming everyone on
that stuff
but if you want you can go through my
dms you can have my phone and you can
have that if that's the stage we're at
yeah would you let me have your phone
passcode yeah
would you really yeah you can have it
now
and then
no i'm joking i'm talking yo you see how
quick i went to the pc
i like this girl you know she's actually
giving me vibes no lie
ah i suppose that's cute are you
confident in the bedroom
yeah
are you though yeah can you say it more
confident i'm saying it with conviction
are you sure you see the level of your
voice or how loud you say it doesn't
mean how confident you are if you know
what you're doing you know what you're
doing do you know what you're doing yeah
really of course i do do you know what
you did no you don't know you're like a
novice
yeah clueless beginner levels it's all
right man teachers are there for a
reason really you're a teacher can be if
you want me to be
maybe
she's feeling me man i can tell she's
feeling me she's looking at me in her
eyes she's feeling me do you have any
fetishes
yes i see i have a foot fetish i can't
lie i would have a foot fetish and
that's about it that's good
yeah that's good
it's like for massages yeah
foot massage every day like every day
yeah every day all right cool
so where are you from so i'm from north
west london like edgar harrero sides i
don't still live there now but that's
where i'm originally from where are you
from are you from london as well no from
around this way you're from this way
yeah all right it's not even too far but
it took me ages to get here today
i know you relate i know sorry about
that i won't be late for our second day
though being late is really rude you
know i know and you know what it is i
won't even blame anyone else apart from
myself but on our second day
i'll be punctual tizzy you've got a lot
of making up to do after being two hours
late what was life like for you as a
teenager then growing up in an area
where there was like a lot of violence
and stuff like that but i never per se
got involved i was friends with everyone
who was involved like literally but i
was never involved myself you get when i
was like 17 music took off for me so
like i had already seen
what you can do from something that's
legit so what are your thoughts on that
on tracking you know i think tracking is
like everyone can do what they want
really i mean pick up all my chaps is
not really a long term thing if you're
trapping to chat for the rest of your
life you're an idiot if you're trapping
maybe to get out of a bad situation
you're in and you have an end goal
you're still a bit of an idiot but like
at least you have a goal money is money
[ __ ] some people don't have
opportunities out here so god do what
you gotta do man my boys gotta make it
out they gotta make it out for example
like just in situations i've seen i've
had friends who have come out of prison
trying to look for a job for weeks
months no jobs because if they've now
got a record so what they're going to do
is go back to doing what they know can
make them the easiest money quick that
my man over here if he's not doing it
this guy is going to be but that's like
a bad attitude because when people think
like that nothing's ever going to change
because someone's always someone's
always going to do it yeah but do you
reckon that you could stop trappers
trapping yeah possibly but you can and
this is the thing when you're flying
demand no but it's the supply and demand
when you stop then eventually things
change like and yes it doesn't know
you're looking at me like
it does but it's just but it's like
there's resources and everything like
that and people just have no ambition
and everyone's money motivated because
it's like especially when you're a teen
or you're a young man you are
everything so impressionable
everything's about image everything's
about money like i was talking to 16
year olds the other day and they want
money what would you need money for
you're 16 but what don't you need money
for yourself if you're 16. everything's
in this hangout in the park or do
something chill world's past that 16
year olds don't want to go hang out in
the park and look at grass i'm telling
you it was past that 16 year olds you
know what they want to do they want to
go to the libs shit's crazy out here
it's just when you have a relaxed
attitude or someone else will do it if
not like it's about having those
conversations and being strong in the in
the mindset of saying actually no this
isn't okay and not just our big up
whoever's doing it that's their
lifestyle no it's not big them up but
it's if you've got to do what you've got
to do to get out of the situation you've
got to do it if this guy's just come out
of prison he's got kids to feed and he
can't get a job he's trying to get legit
jobs and he can't get a job and he knows
that if he does this this and this he's
going to put food on the table really
because then what he does that then he
goes to prison then never gets to see
his kids grow up that's obviously
so men think they think oh yeah do this
do that i know many people that would
much rather a man stay at home just have
a normal job stacking self shelves in
sainsburys is better than trapping
because what you get what i'm showing
you is that one can't even get employed
to stack shelves in sainsbury's when
they have a record like that jamming
it's like the system is set up to
basically break them down yeah but if
they don't start with like with that
because that's therefore not the first
hurdle just start with a normal job i
don't get it there's so many other ways
you can make money
so after all these days why do you think
you haven't found a man yet i'm really
picky
i can see that you know i i did watch
the episodes before i came on i can
bring more to you
yeah i know what i want so what do you
want you since you know what you want
yeah i want consistency
i want honesty
that's literally all i want it's not
even a lot like i'm asking for basic
bare minimum things that men seem to
lack consistency and honesty in this
generation to get that from people's
hearts it's hard and you can't really
trust people nowadays can i trust you
what do you think i'd like to think i
mean i think you can because you know
you asked me the whole cheating question
i was like hella open like the book mad
open with that one so
okay i trust you already you don't even
need to ask me you know you got trust in
eyes thank you yeah i'm a really bad
liar
is it yeah you think i'll be able to
tell you that oh yeah i can't tell
science
i think it's symphony and just a little
do you treat women with respect yeah
because i love my mum and i love women
in general so i think how you treat your
mum
shows a lot and i actually my mum would
respect are you a mommy's boy though
i would that's what everyone says
mummy's boys are the worst why no i love
a man that can respect his mum but
there's a fine line because if you want
mommy's back i know what you're going to
say i know you're going to say i've been
getting asked a lot of questions like
all right cool so if i was to have an
argument with your mum and have to walk
out of the house are you coming with me
like [ __ ] that's the kind of questions
are you coming with me then
it depends what the argument's about it
depends
no because right as much as i'm like
family and you should respect your mum
but what's what's important and what
families need to understand is we
would be potentially the people we're
starting a family together so the fact
that you're already prioritizing your
mom that's dead i'd never know
you think anyone's been coming between
me and my mum's you listen i know what i
said is what i said but [ __ ] my mom's
gonna have to clear on kill you before i
take your side
you gotta be with a man
who has love for his mom and respects
his mom any man that's just gonna say to
you yeah i'll come with you
well that is a waste man i'm sorry i
mean how is it wasted because you don't
even know what the situation is imagine
you was like to my mum i don't want to
say enough at my career but you just
said something crazy out of lying yeah
and then you just slap her or something
with you yeah i mean this is what i'm
trying to say situations
exactly so you don't know what if you
give me a situation i can tell you does
your mom still do your cleaning cooking
no i cook for myself a lot i'm a very
very very good cook i would want the
second date to be i would want to cook
for you do you like seafood yeah i do
all right cool so what i would cook is a
lobster linguine you like pasta yeah i
do loves a linguini carbonara and then
like some sweet chili chicken strips on
the side that's what i would do how many
women have you cooked that for
yeah see i i want you to
can i cook that for no one that's
actually my new dish i've cooked a woman
before i won't lie but that dish there
i've already cooked for my family so
okay
so from the previous episodes to me just
looks like you hate men like would you
say you're anti-men
fancy men no i love men is it yeah
that's why i don't know
but when are you really trying to make a
choice though no i know going on all
these dates but you're gonna have to
choose someone real soon no personally
i'm not in a rush oh you're taking your
time yeah so i mean because i want it to
be right so i'm not just trying to like
choose you just because i need to choose
you no like it has to be the right
person of course i'm looking for a vibe
that i can't get anywhere else do i mean
and it's hard to find it because i think
a lot of people can offer me things
but
it's it's got to be deeper than that
yeah
yeah yeah and i enjoy it as well yeah
there's a tick
like very selective like i don't know
how many people's i've eaten i don't
know how many people have selected it
right so i know how many people how many
then oh you actually want the number
yeah i'll give you a number like i have
to think about it though like briefly
it's that many yeah
um
about four four yeah i don't know why
all these men are so scared to say they
eat man i'm just out here being honest
you might need to stop lying to
yourselves and if you're not doing it
your girl's gonna come over here real
soon so patting up my guy yeah
so how do you know you're good at it
they'll tell you
i don't have to say much oh really yeah
they'll tell you i could just show you
yeah hold on he's watched the show he's
done his research on me he's definitely
telling me what i want to hear right now
how do you feel about splitting a bill
if it's the first day i'm definitely
going to pay
the whole bill
and i probably pay all the time as well
to be honest but
if we're like together in a relationship
then i'm not trying to pay like for the
whole of our life doesn't really need to
be split in the bill i don't really like
splitting the bill i just want to pay it
at once so it's more like if i've taken
you out like so many times maybe one day
you just hit me up so i mean okay yeah
so do you believe in like traditional
relationships like women staying at home
if she wants to do that she can do that
but i believe that any woman that i'm
going to be with is going to be
intelligent enough to not just want to
stay at home and do nothing like
obviously maybe raising the kids in that
but i want you to maybe like have your
own business or something like that even
i can help you do it it doesn't need to
be no mad job like some silly job but
like
go do something if she if she didn't and
you had kids with her would you make her
sign a prenup i can't lie to you when it
comes to that prenup stuff and all of
that my finances are going to be secured
no women have taken 50 of nothing i have
okay but what if this woman raises your
kids yeah for 18 years she then has
nothing to show because she's raised
your kids for 18 years is she not
entitled to anything she has to sign a
prenup are you listen to this right all
right let me give you a scenario
obviously jeff bezos let's talk about
him yeah
he has now given obviously i don't know
how integral she was to how where he
became
so rich right i don't know i can't
remember but it's in the ballpark of 400
or something million
like so imagine i get to that status now
because you've dated me for how and been
my wife from bare years i should give
you 400 million pounds just because i'm
rich it's not really fair is it no but
they said this is a point actually so
what people seem to forget men
especially when they're on this prenup
flex that a good woman helps you build
that get there so then women try and
make a woman sign a prenup and then to
minimize the power of a good woman
that can't run do i look like someone's
gonna sign a prenup if i've helped you
build something
facts it's not about the minimizing the
power of a good woman it's about nobody
does no no it's about how much input
into all this money that i have did you
have yeah but a lot of women have a lot
of impact but when you're on bad terms
the input is then nothing like listen
there's so many women that are bridal
diets but when you're going through a
breakup everything's that's what i would
say they're not going to remember when
she brought him up and done this done
that or raised the kids people forget
that when you're angry and bitter
imagine this i meet a woman when i'm
already rich why should she now come and
take half my riches if she but if she if
you have kids with her and she raises
your kids well if i have kids with any
woman yeah that woman is never gonna ask
for anything else in her whole life
that's the point but i am not planning
to have like a kid of a woman and that's
not my wife i really don't want that to
happen if it happens it happens and i'll
be there but i don't that's not what i'm
looking for well she thinks she's
intimidating in it she don't know that i
can handle this
so how do you find dating
a like attractive women you
and every other girl who's beautiful
has hella options today you can make a
guy fly to the bike i promise you i know
you could do that like with one text not
that i'm saying you would do that guys
need to be able to
understand that
it's not all about the money thing so
you just be yourself
just be a nice guy and you might come
across an attractive at that sheet
i like that
[Music]
are you
i'm gonna say i'm not anymore not
anymore what happened
[Laughter]
sometimes you just have a life
experience that will humble you
i don't even know how that sounds
yeah i would say i'm dominant in the
bedroom like
keep it in mind i will
yeah yeah i'm friends with all my exes
to be honest finally someone that's
actually friends with their ex he gets
it but you know i seen that you would go
like you link up with your exes on one
of the other episodes that's crazy why
is it crazy if you link up for dinner
imagine going on a dinner date with your
ex that's a bit mad yeah but it's
because you say dinner date it makes it
sound mad and what it is if there's
dinner we're going for food yeah that's
a date no we're just going for food that
makes no sense i can't lie that's not
really happening around me you know
picture this
we move in together we're living in our
nice house and you're like i'm going to
meet
joe blogs for
a flipping nice burger and lobster he's
my ex from two years ago but i'm not
gonna go for a fancy i'll just go like
nando okay so you're gonna go nando's
with mr joe yeah and then i'm like cool
i'm at home chilling and then i'm just
gonna think to myself bro i'm making a
sandwich you're saying my goal
is eating nando's with her ex right now
would you want me to go eat nando's with
my ex if i was your man as long as i'm
eaten i've eaten and stuff go eat with
your eggs then
huh
as long as you've eaten yeah so you have
to so you just have to make sure you
just have that i'd look after you like
if i was going to eat my ex i'm not
going to just leave you at home okay
okay so you could say something you have
to still like look after your man it's
not it's not either or like you don't
have a choice on choosing what i guess i
guess when you get to a certain stage i
think it's a certain stage of trust in
it if you if i know
my person to the stage right i know that
they're just going to go to that dinner
and this is a dinner i've been like cool
you might as well tell your ex to bring
his new misses and i'm gonna pull up too
there we go we could all do that yeah
that sounds a lot more fun to me still
[Music]
no do not no
what if it was really high
if it's like a hundred i'm gonna start
caring because where did you pick up 100
bodies like i'm old enough now to
realize that if you've like been having
sex for a certain amount of time a
certain amount of years it's never all
but you're going to pick up a few bodies
i mean but i don't want to see the
people that you've been with if it's
like far away from man i don't really
care because
everyone's really having sex who am i to
say
how many people are having sex with yeah
man i don't care as long as you're gonna
treat me right that's a good answer
[Music]
yeah like what's this instagram i mean i
hate people that care about social media
so much like like also instagram like
like yeah you like this girl's pick you
follow this girl that stuff really
annoys me when people say that to me
yeah but i think it's because it can
lead to insecurities like if you were
liking a bear like insta baddies yeah
exactly that would be a bit like okay
hold on a minute like i get it but what
if i only know insta baddies well
against the baddies whatever that is
yeah i mean what if i only know those
kind of people yeah i like everyone's
picks yeah that's a picture it's not
deep at all firstly i would never even
see because i'm not even looking for who
your likings picks like that's just
weird i'm not checking for that i'm
really checking for what you're doing in
real life actually to be fair to liar
and i know a lot of women feel this way
i swear to god when if i'm feeling
someone
and then i just see their name under
every girl's pick i
it will make me feel good
it will give
i see their names on every girl's clicks
i'm like
like it does make you look desperate
because it's embarrassing i think
especially as women like i'd be like oh
my god like i really like this guy and
then if i'm showing them and then they
see your name everywhere i'm getting
violated in the group that's on the
girls side i mean yeah that's why i just
would try not to like every girl's pick
would you say your alpha of course what
else would that be what's the other
option if you're not alpha why are you
when you're just not office like where
is it
[Laughter]
how would you feel if i had like a lot
of male friends i mean
i wouldn't like it i got female friends
i can do it in it but i know 99 of you
guys can't you guys are too hungry i
know what you're on man i know what
you're on depends who the guys are and i
need to meet them as well because me
personally i just feel like i've got a
lot of female friends as well right and
it's not like i want to sleep with them
or anything but i just know that other
guys
have bad intentions like today you're
gonna be like that's my best friend
that's my best to you but to his guys
he's like yeah that's that chanting you
know honestly i'm just chilling with her
now we're just chilling but yeah i'm
gonna hit that soon you gotta like say
it's like i don't really and i just know
that's what people's mindsets like i
know when when a beautiful girl
most girl guys just want to chill with
them i have to have her there for good
luck or whatever it is i just want to
make sure that's really a friend it
depends where the friendship came from
have you ever suffered with mental
health issues i haven't but you know
i've got loads of people around me who i
love friends family who i can talk to if
i'm ever feeling down and anyone else
who's out there she does fall down i
think the best thing to do speak to
people speak to people even if it's a
life like my ex called me the other day
she was down i was there for her to get
yeah he's very in touch
what would you do if i slept with two of
your friends i'll just have to decide
how much i like you to see if i could if
it's worth to eat it with or not it
depends which friends
if you so if you sleep with certain
friends i could never go there
yeah what if i wanted to start not only
fans i'll
talk to you about it and say that that's
very very stupid but you know if you've
wanted to do it and like sell like foot
picks or like pics you're putting on the
gram feel free only fans
i'm your only fan you get it me i'm the
only fan simple
what if it was like
body picks
like what naked yeah
i'm not really
to be honest like but obviously it
depends like if you've been doing it
before i came into the situation and i
come in accepting it i can't talk but if
you want to start doing that while we're
together i'm going to give you my
opinion oh so that's like the energy you
should come with when you talk about
trap stars and stuff like that is it
relatable
so when people are like
trying to do things for their hustle
yeah you know like like you said earlier
it's their hustle that's their bag yeah
well let's see
this is why i don't
like hate on not only fans girls because
i think if there's guys out there who
want to pay to see pics they can see on
instagram damn take their money
they're very stupid so take the money
like why not i can put my goal onto a
million different ways to make money you
don't need to do that like i can teach
you crypto why would you do early fans i
can show you how to make
bear money what would you do if i got
put in prison for two years let's say
you're inside for two years and you're
seven one
porn for one year or two
damn i mean i think i'd leave still
would you
yeah we're in love we're in love but
like
it really depends what you did like
really depends you know why that
actually annoys me it really depends
what you did
but so men always say how they want a
ride or diet i don't want nobody to wait
for me but men would usually
okay so i wouldn't wait for you then no
if i go to prison yeah just leave me
there when you come out maybe we can get
back together but for two years
i don't see how it's possible but maybe
say for example if you've got kids and
it's all loving and that then yeah
that's different it really depends what
kind of relationship we have what if i
didn't sleep with your first six months
are you waiting
for you yeah
but i'll get your vibrator you might
need that i i personally believe what
would happen was if you was to actually
speak to me for six months
you would want it to happen faster than
that oh really that's what i think like
i think that naturally it would just
happen faster i'm kind of a person when
i'm seeing someone i want to see them a
lot so
if we're linking up all the time it's
just naturally gonna happen way before
six months i think i think women we just
like the fault of a man willing to wait
yeah they're not trying to rush yeah i
don't really care about sex like there's
porn right i've got a right hand for a
reason i don't really care so like six
months ain't that deep but i just don't
think you would wait six months if it
was me
tizzy how do you think you've done
i think i don't know right like i mean
this feels like it's been a good
conversation i've got to know a bit more
about you
and you're smart which is i like it
interesting can cheers on that
how do you think the date's gone
nice it's going nice
it's going really nice oh the day went
good man i think she saw that i'm an
intelligent guy i saw she's an
intelligent girl i mean i didn't even
ask her if she was attracted to me but i
think she was by the eye contact i'm
attracted to her and pretty sure we're
going to see each other again
you know what it was a good date with
conversation wise but i'm not really
feeling the chemistry there wasn't any
i'll definitely see her again like um
[ __ ] like next week
as friends
what grilling i the show is called
grilling i didn't feel good at all i'm
not even cooked yet b he handled it
because he was telling me what i wanted
to hear
so she's going to write you about 10.
all right what do you think she's going
to give you
i reckon
she's going to give me an eight
i that's very generous
not an eight
and if she doesn't give me an eight then
she's just capping to herself is what it
is seven point five i'll take as well
but um
i'm gonna give tizzy a five he's a nice
guy i feel like he was telling me what i
wanted to hear a little too much and i
don't think there was that much
chemistry
[Music]
you